the yellow mustache the yellow hair the
big green eyes he's bernie brewer the
milwaukee brewers mascot
bernie is the heart and soul of the
brewers but who is bernie he's actually
based on milt mason a real life brewers
fanatic
in the late 1970s a 69 year old mason
decided that he would perch himself on
top of the stadium's scoreboard he vowed
not to come down until a crowd of at
least 40 thousand people came to see a
brewer's game a little over a month
later 44 387 people filled the stadium
and milt now a hero came down from his
perch few years later in 1973 bernie
brewer became the official mascot of the
milwaukee brewers
just like milt mason bernie knew how to
make an entrance he first emerged from a
beer-barreled chalet and after every
home run he would slide down from his
perch into a beer stein
sadly in 1984 the brewers tore down
bernie's perch and pushed him into
retirement
that didn't last long however and in
1993 brewers fans voted and brought
bernie back
bernie brewer back on his scoreboard
perch has no plans of retiring anytime
soon
you